مسبك الجرس منذ العصور الوسطى
في أراضينا
في إيطاليا كان هناك الكثير من الحضور
لسوء الحظ حتى الآن ، فقد ظللنا
القليل في القليل
[موسيقى]
أنا باسكوال مارينيلي عائلتي
صنع الأجراس من عام ألف عمل
من العصور الوسطى واليوم نعمل
لا يزالون كما عملوا في العصور الوسطى
[موسيقى]
أنا وأخي أرماندو ينبغي
أن يكون الجيل السادس والعشرون
استمر في عمل الأجراس قبل الانتشار
جرس نعلم جميع المعلمات و
قبل كل شيء نعرف الجدة والصوت
والتي ستنبعث منها الجرس
برج الجرس
كل ملاحظة تتوافق مع قطر
جرس في أي مكان في العالم
سمعت في جرسنا
التعرف على أنه أمر سهل ، لذلك سيكون كذلك
صوت معين
يمكن التعرف عليه في ذلك الوقت
نقوم بدمج الأجراس هناك الكثير من
فريق عملنا
يمكننا أن نعطي روحًا للجرس
وأحد أهم عملائنا
طبعا اجمل لحظة يا ابي
من حياتي عندما جون مع
الثاني دخل هذا الرجل المجنون
لجميع الأجداد الذين يراقبوننا
بسيط يمكنني أن أؤكد أن هذا هو
كانت تلك اللحظة
جمال أعمالنا فن
التي تحملها في الداخل ويجب عليك بعد ذلك
أنقل لمن سيأتي بعدك
أتمنى أن يكون أطفالي متحمسين
بنفس الطريقة
[موسيقى]